one year ago we arrived on a piece of
land we just bought in portugal
we came with one van on a big piece of
land
with a lot of rain falling like a lot it
rains more here than in london near the
netherlands it was raining all day
i wasn't really prepared for that i mean
portugal should be sunny
so it meant daily wet socks and trying
to dry stuff in a very humid van
there wasn't much here we got water from
a local tap and this was the toilet
that's a poo pool and the goal for this
year was to set up a base camp
set up some basic infrastructure so we
can be here with more people so here we
have our first campfire get it campfire
yeah good joke anyway there was a lot of
work to do and this video has all the
progress we made in one year
[Music]
so the land is big it's 10 hectares
and at this point we haven't really seen
the entire land only with a drone
because it's really hard to access
everything
fully overgrown with thorns so we
started making pathways so we need to go
through the bushes somewhere here
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so we made a pot all around the land and
we could walk around much better wait
let me actually give you a better
perspective of the land to keep an
overview so we go here the land is here
and this is the pot we just made
let's keep a list of all the things we
did make pathways check and as a
reference here's the highest point on
the land it has a big rock
this is what the view looks like from
here
now with pathways we can explore much
more and doing so we started seeing some
things
like over here we saw a puddle of water
we got curious to how big it was so we
cleared up the space around it
we removed a lot of spiky bushes and
chopped down a bunch of dead trees
and while doing all of this we also
found a few random things in there
wow
cowboy
what's happening in this part looks like
burnt plastic
also find some more stuff like this
metal from a motorbike
[Applause]
so now it's ready okay it still looks a
bit rough but this little swamp could
potentially be a place to swim in the
future
and just for your reference this little
swamp is located right here on the map
but from some neighbors we actually hear
there should be a bigger water source on
the land right there
but looking from above it should be
somewhere hidden between these bushes
it's hard to imagine but when we walked
down we noticed it does look like
something is there
underneath these dead trees
so we started to drag them out and clear
it up
matia took a little dip first swim of
the year
22nd of february to be nice and lovely
[Applause]
and it turned out to be quite a big
reservoir of water
before
after and all of this work is quite fun
discovering these new things on the land
but it's also intense because at this
point we have very basic tools we really
needed to start setting up our base camp
so a few months ago before we came to
the land we got two old shipping
containers
we needed them to move our stuff to the
land but we figured if we move a
container anyway let's also turn them
into something useful not just a box to
ship things
so we converted one container in a fully
equipped workspace with all our tools
and the other one we call the town
center and it has all the basic
utilities like a kitchen fridge washing
machine things like that
so once we build them we pack them up
and send them off
[Music]
and they came to portugal with some very
sketchy unloading kind of scary moment
it felt like they could fall at any
point
i mean it's a fully packed shipping
container on two individual forklifts
and a muddy road
but at this moment they're not on the
land yet just in a storage place close
by because before they could come we
still have to make some space
so we currently have the base camp
installed on this grass patch where we
have the two shipping containers coming
so i want to clear up a little bit the
bushes and thorns here until the trees
so the containers can go there and we
have a bit more space
which means yeah taking down a few more
spiky bushes and leveling the floor to
make sure the containers are parked flat
so finally they got dropped off on the
land luckily everything went okay they
arrived in one piece and first they
dropped the workspace and then the
kitchen
and this was a big upgrade we suddenly
have a lot of tools and a place to be
dry
we call this base camp this is the main
place where you'll camp out in the
coming years as we work on the land so
we figured let's make it nice around
here
we started cleaning up the area around
it remove some spiky bushes level the
soil and plant a herbal garden with some
flowers
[Music]
shhh
[Music]
and at this point the place looks nice
and we have this fully equipped kitchen
and workspace however there's no
electricity yet so we can't use anything
so we made a big metal frame to mount on
top of the container
we installed the solar panels on the
roof
installed all the components for our
solar system
and connected all the cables
okay moment of truth everything is wired
up solar panels coming in here the only
thing breaking the circuit is the fuse
box so if we
put this one on everything should work
so let's see
that seems to work to be honest this was
quite a magical moment suddenly we could
use everything like the blender
but besides electricity we needed
another crucial thing water
because up until this point all the
water we use still comes from our
jerrycans
we refill them in a village nearby and
bring them to the land
but actually the upside of all the rain
is that there's plenty of water around
us
so we found an old abandoned well on a
spring on the land of the neighbors
and the spring is right here and they
turn it into a well but it's abandoned
and not used for many years so we asked
the neighbor if we could use his well
and clean it up and he said yes
so we cleaned up the area around it and
opened it up
it looks impressive
but first a little swim you know quality
control
yeah maybe not the best for drinking
so we asked some guys to help out
cleaning it frida asked them to mount a
gopro on their head
so they got in there and emptied the
well we got some funny footage from that
and once it was done we started digging
the pipes in the ground we connected all
the tubes above the ground
and we assembled all the parts for the
water system which is using a pressure
tank
and we installed everything
so rita can you show the water yes the
water look at this
water
[Music]
water
water
it's cold
and finally also shower well sort of
a few weeks later we upgrade to a decent
shower
so we now have hot showers
yeah this is good
so now we have local water powered on
solar energy
but one thing missing after six months
an upgrade to the poop hole
it got kind of essential at this point
so ian came and he built a nice little
compost toilet
with a seed from recycled plastic
works with sawdust and you add a scoop
after you poop
so at this moment we have water
electricity a dry space and a shower
it's quite a proper base camp with good
utilities
and it's set up right there
so now it's time to work a bit more on
the land
now it's getting pretty hot in summer
but we have a little stream on the land
but it's covered again with bushes
so our moms came to help out and clean
it up
take away dead trees and thorns so we
can access the fresh flowing water
now we have a nice place to swim and
refresh
we also build a little dam from some
rocks and the water rises so we can take
a dip
and this stream we cleared is located
right there at the edge of the land
but what we actually really wanted to
clear up was a little ruin located here
on the land
it's a small building built on a granite
foundation and apparently was a kitchen
in the old days
also fully overgrown and hard to access
we chopped down the overgrowing thorns
so we could go around it
cleared the inside which was for some
reason full of soil
and we took down the almost collapsing
roof
it was really nice to finally be able to
access this building
and it has quite a beautiful location
with a view on the field
now we have one more room to clean and
this one scared us actually a bit
because it's way way bigger and way more
overgrown
it's hidden here between the bushes so
we invited some friends to help us clear
it
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
and after a few days we managed to take
out all the spiky bushes and trees that
are grown into it now we can take
measurements and make a plan on what to
do with it you will see more of that in
season two
and here you can see how they are
positioned on the land
big rune small ruin base camp
so as you might have guessed it's right
there on the map
and by now we actually became quite good
friends with the neighbors they're
always driving with their tractors
seeing what's going on
most of them are above 60 and they grow
up around this land they know it inside
out
i don't think they really understand
what we're doing i mean we're not even
really sure but they like it
and they might be older but they're
still very active and happy to help out
using their tractors to connect a wood
chipper and ship some trees or help us
to move big stuff
and they also often bring us food which
they grow on their own land potatoes
fernanda
the neighbor the neighbors
look at this
it's really nice
and in exchange we help them a bit
harvesting things like
potatoes or grapes for their wine
and besides making friends with
neighbors we also observed a lot of
friends around
little birds that eat our leftover bread
caterpillars that are walking around to
our pathways
or
slowly eating our plants
bit by bit
frogs from the swamp
goats and sheep from the neighbors that
eat our grass and probably this is the
friendliest friend we have a guest for
dinner tonight
yeah they always drop by to see what's
going on we have very welcoming friends
so towards the end of the year winter is
approaching it's getting colder and the
days are shorter
we noticed something missing up until
now everything was very practical like
getting water electricity toilet we
needed a fun social activity in our
routine so we made a pizza oven from
clay and another essential thing needed
for it was a roof to keep it dry
because yeah remember more rains here
than the netherlands or i guess italy
so we gathered some materials
and we used some roof dials from the big
ruin we just cleaned up
and we built a wooden structure with it
[Music]
a roof to protect from the rain in the
winter
so now we can just work outside when it
rains without getting wet
which is a big upgrade but more
importantly we can bake pizza all year
round
so it's now raining
we eat pizza dried
now this is our saturday routine big
delicious pizzas
and the pizza oven is set up right here
in the middle of base camp so we can eat
as much as possible breakfast lunch
dinner midnight snack
and finally a last build of the year a
roof in front of the town center
because every time it rains it gets all
muddy inside when the sun shines it gets
very hot so we made a wooden structure
with an experimental roof made from
recycled plastic sheets
it's a bit of a living prototype
we're not sure how it's gonna go but
let's see
all right so that was uh season one
compressed into a short video
it was quite an intense year i would say
a lot of things to do uh it was very raw
when we first came on the land and all
the rain and just the van
um but there's something very satisfying
about really starting basic and see
small upgrades like the first time we
had a cutter for the bushes or having
electricity or water really makes you
appreciate these basic things
which is really nice to
be part of that and the goal of this
year was to set up a base camp to have a
place where we can be with more people
and set up some basic infrastructure
so it was mainly me and rita here on the
land
and some friends and family came to help
here and there
and throughout time towards the end of
the year adrian and julie came to help
out for longer periods of time
but the goal is really to not do too
much on the land itself and because we
first wanted to see where we even are
what does the land need what is the plan
we're going to do before we start
chopping down and intervening too much
so the goal was to set up a base camp so
we can invite more people to come and
help out and meanwhile think of a good
plan and we've been doing that we have a
base camp now we thought of a good plan
and that's what we're going to do in
season two so in the next video we're
going to show you the plan of all the
things you want to do this year that's a
lot but it's also exciting and we're
going to be with more people so more
hands more work to be done
if you already want to see that video
you can support us on patreon so you see
the video one week ahead
and you just support the project as well
that was it for this video thanks for
watching exciting to start season two
hope you guys are as well and see you
coming monday every monday three o'clock